بنصيحه ذهبيه لتحسين الصحه واللياقه
البدنيه والاهم دون تمارين حقيقيه سحر
اعجبني الموضوع سحر هذا من الممكن طبعا
وهذه عبر دراسه امريكيه وجدت ان اضافه ما
وصفته بالاطعمه الخارقه للنظام الغذائي
يعادل للمشي 4000 خطوه اضافيه في اليوم
مزبوط الدراسه اجريت على اكثر من 2000 شخص
في الاعتبار مستويات النشاط البدني حتى
بين الرياضيين انفسهم النتائج اكدتها
الارتباط القوي بين النمط الغذائي وتحسن
اللياقه البدنيه وارجحت السبب الى ان
الانظمه الصحيه تساعد الجسم على حرق اكثر
لسعرات الحراريه اضافه ايضا الى تقليل من
مخاطر الاصابه بامراض القلب والسرطان
نتعرف في شرح التالي على الاطعمه الخارقه
بحسب هذه الدراسه
[موسيقى]
الينا خبيره التغذيه صباح الاشقر صباح يا
صباح السعاده صباح الورد يا اهلا وسهلا
صباح اليوم يعني هذه الدراسه الامريكيه
اولا دراسات كثيره ولكن بالفعل هناك اطعمه
خارقه تساعدنا يعني ما نمارس رياضه ونروح
لهذه الاطعمه والله هلا اشوفها لمجرد احنا
دراسه معناتها هذا الشيء صار وصار على
اشخاص لحتى هني فصلوا لهي النتيجه هلا في
شغله دائما نحن في توازن بين كل شيء يعني
هلا انت بتعرف احنا لنحافظ على جسم صحي
لازم نكون الداخل مثل الخارج يعني على
كميه الاكل اللي عملناكلها لازم يكون في
حرق لهذه السعرات تمام اذا نحافظ على
وزننا داخل قد الخارج يعني العمل
حرقه اذا كنا بدنا ننزل وزنها لازم ناكل
اخف من كميه الحرق اللي عم بتصير اكيد في
اطعمه مثل
الفواكه الحمضيه مثل التوت مثل
الليمون هذا فيهم الاحماض الالفا
هذه تماما هاي بتساعد على حرق الدهون في
عنا الاسماك الدهنيه هاي فيها الاوميجا 3
كمان هي بتحفز وبتساعد كمان على انه هي
ترفع وتعزز معدل الايض ومن هيك الدراسه
عملها بتحكي عن انه اذا بناكل هاي الاطعمه
بنقدر نقلل من العمل البدني او الجهد
البدني ممكن نوصل لانه هي بتساعد على حرق
تساعد على حرق الدهون بالجسم اعطينا هيك
ليست او يعني شي مفصل ممكن المشاهدين
واحنا نستفيد منه بانه اذا بناكل هاي هي
السوبر فودز احنا بنحكي عن السوبر فودز
هلا شوف هلا طبعا بالاكل مثل ما قلت لكم
الفواكه الحمضيه مهمه الخضار اللي فيها هي
عباره عن اوراق خضراء مثل
السبانخ مثل الكروم في عنا كمان الخضروات
بكل انواعها المكسرات والبذور في عنا
كثير مهمين كمان لانه كمان بيساعد على
امتصاص الدهون للجسم في عنا الكركم كركم
هذا اذا غليناه وشربناه هذا بيمنع تراكم
الدهون بالجسم وبنفس الوقت بيسحب الدسم من
الجسم لما بناكل شيء دسم هذه الدراسه قالت
بانها يعادل الاكل هذه الاطعمه 4000 خطوه
بالتالي نقلل يعني الكل شخص ربما المعدل
يكون عشره الاف خطوه في اليوم طب هذا كانه
انا عامل 14 الف خطوه في اليوم هلا مو هي
هي مجموعه الاكل يعني يعني هلا انت مثلا
احنا بالشغل معنا وقت للممارس الرياضه
بنحاول ضمن وجباتنا الاكل اللي عم ناكله
نحن يكون في هي الاطعمه اللي مثل مثلا
الزنجبيل الشاي الاخضر بعد كل وجبه مثلا
نشرب شاي اخضر
الكيميو طبعا اكيد لانه الحمضيات
هلا شوف بالاخير بالاخير يعني فينا يعني
هو الطبيعي انه فينك تاخد من وحده يعني
تنتين ثلاثه
نحن بالاخير اهم شيء ما ناخذه بشكل عصير
لانه يعني في شغله انه بالفواكه كمان فيها
سكر بتروح الفايده يعني او سكريات يعني
نحن انت انت لما بتاكلي هو بالاخير جهاز
العصبي بده عشرين دقيقه ليصلوا اشعار
الاحساس بالشبع فانت لما بتاخدي اي اكل عن
طريق سائل ما بقى بتحسي انك انت اكلتي
يعني انت ممكن تاكسي
صحيح طيب حبيت اني اسالك صباح عن هل بيفرق
متى نتناول هذه السوبر فود الصبح الظهر
بالليل ولا ما بتفرق هلا هلا بتفرق لصحتنا
يعني نحن ما فينا ناكل حمضيات على معده
فاضيه هذا كثير غلط لانه بياثر على المعده
صحيح اثنين هدول يعني كيف بدي اقول لك
هدول لازم يكونوا سناكات بين الوجبات
الوجبه الاساسيه لازم اهم شيء نحن انه نحن
ناخذ البروتين الكفايه لانه هذا العضل حتى
الكربوهيدرات المفيده هي كمان ضروريه لانه
هي بتعطينا طاقه وبنفس الوقت بتحافظ على
منسوب السكر بالدم
الاغذيه الغنيه بالحديد لانه كمان بتساعد
على نقل الدم بالجسم بحيث انه هي
كل كل
يعني كلو بصير فيه امتصاص مضبوط فيها
للجسم بقى ما في اوقات معينه بس المهم
تماما يعني يكونوا يقولوا السكريات اللي
موجوده بالفواكه تحرق اصعب من السكر
العادي فبالتالي يجب ان نبكر فيها هذه
النقطه وهل الروح على الفواكه اللي فيها
الياف اكثر اكيد الالياف اول شغله هي
بتريح المعده وبنفس الوقت بتعطي احساس
بالشبع لفتره اطول عرفت علي هلا بالنسبه
للسكر هو سكر هو سكر طبيعي هذا كثير مفيد
للجسم بس احنا بنفضل ما ناخذه قبل يعني
بالليل لانه هو في دراسات بتقول انه انت
على الاقل لازم اربع ساعات قبل النوم انك
انت ما تاكلي شكرا جزيلا لك صباح الاشقر
خبيره التغذيه على كل هذه النصائح
مشاهديكم بهذه الاطعمه يلا لمتابعتي
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات